Europe is now entering the weird and  wonderful world of negative interest  rates so what has brought the European  Central Bank to this well first of all  they want to prevent deflation eurozone  inflation is well below 2% and nearing  negative territory second they need to  avoid a stagnant economy third there are  rules that prevent ECB from doing Bank  of England style quantitative easing all  of which is why President Mario Draghi  has decided to cut the rate the central  bank pays out on deposits held there  from zero to minus nine point one  percent and that would being consumer  banks will have to pay to leave money  there the hope is this is going to  encourage them to go out and lend that  money boosting economic activity will it  work well Denmark and Sweden have both  experimented with negative rates but  with mixed results the reality is as  with QE this is yet another step into  the unknown